we're going to begin with the news and
the news this morning is not good in
Vermont a disaster there are several
communities are almost completely cut
off by water this morning and more than
50 people have had to be rescued after
hours of heavy rain officials are
warning of an unprecedented amount of
water that could be released by local
dams putting nearby towns in Jeopardy
this morning Meg Oliver is in hard hit
Londonderry Vermont May good morning
what are you seeing where you are
Tony good morning residents here in
Londonderry are waking up to more scenes
of Destruction like this behind me where
this bridge has collapsed but the most
severe damage is about 20 minutes north
of here in Ludlow we tried for hours
yesterday to access the town but every
road we went down was either blocked by
debris or washed out by water I talked
to one business owner over the phone
last night Tony Caruso who described the
scene as complete devastation
dangerous thunderstorms moved across the
Northeast Monday slamming the region
with up to eight inches of rain and
catastrophic flooding that's the soccer
field in Vermont a state of emergency as
several feet of water flooded Parks
destroyed homes and rushed down roads
and highways
surveillance video shows the powerful
flood bursting into this restaurant's
kitchen top Lane and ice machine before
quickly filling the room with water
and from above you can see the city of
Ludlow isolated as flooding shut down
all main roads leading in and out of
town first thing I saw was my car
underwater this is the worst this has
ever been similar scenes in nearby Mount
Holly obviously the driveway is gone our
truck out front looks like it washed
away a little bit Nikki and Jay umel are
stranded at their home after flood
waters overwhelm their driveway they
spoke to CBS affiliate WCAX by phones
from across the
streets when you look out the window and
you see a 60-foot wide river going
through your front yard Cindy Byers is
cleaning up her yard after water
surrounded her Stony Point New York
house late Sunday night we didn't think
it was going to be that bad well we
thought it was just going to flood on
the lawn like usual a little bit her
husband Richard had to be evacuated by
boat power of that water it's
unbelievable you didn't want to put me
unconscious
now that the rain has finally stopped
the flood waters will start to recede
today and the extensive cleanup will
begin one resident told us even the
damage from Hurricane Irene in 2011
doesn't compare to what they're seeing
today Nate
Meg thank you